ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON REVENUE
AND TAXATION DO THE PANDEMIC WE
ARE CONTINUE TO PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ARE ABLE
WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING
A MASK YOU MORNING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING THE MAINTAINED BY
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR AT THE VERY VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES
TESTIMONY TODAY IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THAT TIME I WOULD
ASK THE PUBLIC NOT TO TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'VE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE HEARING ROOM
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON. AT A TIME.
FOR DIALING WITNESSES. WE WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE THROUGH WHICH- ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALLING NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AN ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR. TWO ZERO
TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THAT
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY REVENUE
AND TAX COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU ARE CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN
TO DO SO AS SOON AS POSSIBLE WE
HAVE ONLY A LIMITED NUMBER OF
BILLS CITY ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
IF YOU ARE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCASTS AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. IF YOU HAVE
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE
A PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2098 MY
STUFF WILL BE THERE TO HELP YOU.
I ALSO WANT TO KNOW THAT WE'RE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TERRIBLE.
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. NOW FOR A FEW
ADDITIONAL HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR THE BILLS
BEING TAKEN UP TODAY WE WILL
TAKE NO MORE THAN TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OR WITH
CONCERNS. THESE WITNESSES WERE
UP TWO MINUTES EACH PROVIDE
THEIR TESTIMONY ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHOULD STATE THEIR
NAME THE ORGANIZATION AND THE
POSITION ONLY. IT LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE A QUORUM. MR OF WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CALL THE ROLL. BURKE
HERE. WHEN GREAT. GRAYSON
LEVINE. MAYES THERE MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK HERE
THREE OF US SAY AUTO. YOU HAVE
A COURT. ALL RIGHT. I WITH THAT
WILL MOVE TO THE FIRST A GENOM
ITEM WHICH IS AB TWELVE OH
THREE OF WHICH ARE PRESENTING
SO I'M HANDING THIS OVER. TO
RIGHT THANK YOU MANAGER
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. RIGHT.
US SO FIRST I'LL BE ACCEPTING
THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE AB
TWELVE OH THREE SPONSORED BY
THE LAW COUNTY LOS ANGELES IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT WILL ENABLE
TAXPAYERS TO DISPUTE PROPERTY
ASSESSMENTS ANYMORE TIMELY
MANNER. IT WOULD SIMPLY EXPAND
THE POOL OF POTENTIAL OPTIONS
FOR SERVICE ON THE ASSESSMENT
APPEALS BOARD IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WHILE ALSO PERMITTING
BILL L. A. COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. TO REDUCE THE
THREE YEAR WAITING PERIOD. THAT
FLOOR FORMER SISTERS EMPLOYEES
ARE SUBJECT TO BEFORE BECOMING
ELIGIBLE TO SERVE ON AN APPEALS
BOARD TO NO LESS THAN ONE YEAR.
SHOULD THEY SEE FIT DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC ALL IN PERSON APPEAL
HEARINGS IN THE COUNTY WERE
HALTED FROM MARCH TWENTIETH TO
OCTOBER OF MY MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY. CONSEQUENTLY THE NUMBER
OF OPEN APPEALS APPLICATIONS
REQUIRING HANG HAS GROWN FROM
260-007-0040 ONE TO THIRTY
EIGHT THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY A 44% INCREASE. BUT THE
APPLICATION DEADLINE CLOSING IN
JUNE THE TOTAL NUMBER IS ONLY
EXPECTED TO GROW CONTINUE
TRENDING UPWARDS THIS BACKLOG
MUST BE ADDRESSED. LAST YEAR WE
PASSED LEGISLATION THAT REMOVES
THE CAP ON THE NUMBER OF PILLS
BOARD BOARDS PERMITTED IN A
COUNTY. ADDITIONAL BOARDS WERE
CREATED L. A. AS RESULT IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE WORKLOAD
ALTHOUGH THE COUNTY CREATED NEW
BOARDS TO BE MORE RESPONSIVE TO
TAXPAYERS THEY HAVE BEEN
CHALLENGES FINING PEOPLE TO
SERVE THIS IS THE PROBLEM AB
TWELVE OH THREE ADDRESSES. IF
THE COUNTY IS TO ADDRESS THIS
CRITICAL BACKLOG WE MUST
PROVIDE IT WITH THE FLEXIBILITY
TO EXPAND THE UNIVERSE OF
POTENTIAL APPEAL BOARD MEMBERS
TO OTHERS FROM THE REAL ESTATE
FIELD. THEY ARE JUST AS
QUALIFIED AS CURRENT BOARD
MEMBERS ARE I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE CONCERNS REGARDING
THE OVERALL APPEALED FOR
PROCESSING AND I WELCOME SO
THOSE CONVERSATIONS HOWEVER.
THE INTENTION OF THIS MOTHER
MEASURE IS NOT TO REFORM THE
PROCESS. I REPEAT. THE PURPOSE
OF THIS BILL IS NOT TO REFORM
THE PROCESS BUT RATHER. TO
SIMPLY PROVIDE L. A. COUNTY
WITH THE FLEXIBILITY. TO
RECRUIT POTENTIAL AB MEMBERS IN
ORDER TO MAXIMIZE THE USE OF
THE ADDITIONAL BOARDS THAT WERE
CREATED TO ADDRESS THE APPEALS
AND A TIMELY MATTER. IN
RESPONSE TO OPPOSITION CLAIMS I
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
EXISTING PROVISIONS PREVENT.
FORMER ASSESSOR EMPLOYEES FROM
HEARING CASES THAT THEY
THEMSELVES WORKED ON DURING
THEIR TIME AS AN EMPLOYEE OF
THE ASSESSOR'S OFFICE. DESPITE
WHAT MEAL IT MAY HAVE BEEN TOLD
THAT IS CURRENT ALREADY CORRECT.
THIS IS A LOW COST
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND NECESSARY
MEASURES THAT WILL BENEFIT THE
TAXPAYERS OF L. A. COUNTY. WITH
ME IN SUPPORT OVER THE PHONE R.
JR JEREMY GRAY CHIEF DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY'S EXECUTIVE
OFFICE AND JEFF CRANE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ASSESSOR'S. THE
BILL. THANK YOU I UNDERSTAND
THERE ARE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT I WOULD ASK THE
MODERATE TO CONNECT US FIRST
WITH JEREMY GRAY OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. MR ME YES THIS IS
JEREMY THIS IS YOUR ME GREAT
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES THANK YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JEREMY GRAY
FOR THE RECORD I AM THE CHIEF
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER. OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OUR OFFICE MANAGES
THE COUNTY'S ASSESSMENT APPEALS
PROGRAM. I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE FOR
AUTHORING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THIS BILL WOULD ASSESS THE
COUNTY. OF LOS ANGELES IN
RECRUITING QUALIFIED CANDIDATES
WHO ARE NOT AVAILABLE TO US
UNDER EXISTING LAW. TO FIELD
VACANCY ON OUR ASSESSMENT
APPEALS BOARD AND THEREBY HELP
THE COUNTY ADDRESS A VOLUME OF
APPEALS AND ASSOCIATED BACKLOG.
I SHOULD FIRST POINT OUT THAT
OUR COUNTY BY FAR THE LARGEST
APPEALS WORKLOAD IN THE STATE.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE
RECEIVED NEARLY AS MANY APPEALS
AS THE NEXT FIVE LARGEST
COUNTIES COMBINED. CONSEQUENTLY
IT IS CLEAR THAT WE NEED TO
CREATE MORE ASSESSMENT APPEALS
BOARDS THEN WE HAVE
HISTORICALLY HAD. THIS WILL
REQUIRE MANY MORE. ASSESSMENT
APPEALS MEMBERS AB TWELVE ALL
THREE WILL HELP US TO INCREASE
THE POOL OF QUALIFIED
CANDIDATES FOR APPOINTMENT BY
INCLUDING INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
FIVE YEARS OF RELEVANT
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE IN REAL
ESTATE. URBAN PLANNING LAND USE
PROFESSIONS THAT ARE NOT
AVAILABLE TO US CURRENTLY. THE
BILL ALSO WOULD GIVE THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS THE OPTION TO
REDUCE OF THE WAITING PERIOD
FOR APPOINTMENT OF EXTRASENSORY
EMPLOYEES FROM THREE YEARS TO
ONE YEAR A VERY COMMON
PROVISION IN STATE FEDERAL AND
LOCAL- REVOLVING DOOR STATUTES
AND ORDINANCES. WE RECOGNIZE
THAT AB TWELVE ALL THREE WOULD
NOT BE THE TOTAL SOLUTION THUS
WE HAVE BEGUN TO REACH OUT MORE
AGGRESSIVELY TO CURRENT
QUALIFIED PERSONS. WHILE WE
FACE SEVERE BUDGETARY PROBLEMS.
ALL BY THE PANDEMIC WE HAVE
PRIORITIZED I REQUEST TO
INCREASE THE COMPENSATION THAT
AB MEMBERS RECEIVE WHICH OUR
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WILL
EVALUATE ALONG WITH MANY OTHER
CRITICAL FUNDING REQUEST. AB
TWELVE ALL THREE ALONG WITH
OTHER STEPS WILL GIVE US THE
CAPACITY WE NEED TO MORE
QUICKLY HOLD APPEAL HEARINGS SO
THAT TAXPAYER AND ASSESSORS
RECEIVED. DUE PROCESS THEY
DESERVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
UP NEXT WE HAVE THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ASSESSOR JEFFREY PRANG.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- IN OUR WILL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE OH THREE I AM JUST
PRAYING I AM THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ASSESSOR. I'M VERY
GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE IS LEADING THE EFFORT TO
ADDRESS A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ASSESSMENT APPEALS
PROCESS LATEST BUDGET DOES HAVE
CHANGES ARE NECESSARY FOR L. A.
COUNTY TO UPDATE ITS ASSESSMENT
APPEALS PROGRAM TO IMPROVE BOTH
EFFICIENCY FOR THE COUNTY. AND
EXPEDIENCY FOR TAXPAYERS IN
RESOLVING THEIR DISPUTES OVER
ASSESSMENTS. AB TWO OR THREE
WILL ALLOW L. A. COUNTY TO
IMPROVE THE PROCESS BY
EXPANDING THE POOL OF QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS WHO COULD SERVE ON
ASSESSMENT APPEALS BOARD WHICH
WILL CONTRIBUTE TO OUR ONGOING
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE THIS SYSTEM
WHILE PROVIDING TAXPAYERS. WITH
MORE EFFICIENT EXPEDIENT AND
EQUITABLE PROCESS FOR THEIR
APPEALS. THIS YEAR'S SCOPE OF
THE CASE LOAD UP IN APPEALS .
A. COUNTY REQUIRES URGENT
LEGISLATIVE ACTION THE CASELOAD
HAS INCREASED FROM ABOUT
200-002-2000 AND MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY- TO OVER FORTY
THOUSAND TODAY WELL THERE ARE
MANY- REASONS WHY THE NUMBER OF
APPEALS HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED COVERED NINETEEN
AMONG THEM. THE FACT IS THE L.
A. COUNTY DOES NOT HAVE A
SUFFICIENT STRUCTURE OR
RESOURCES. TO MANAGE THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT CASELOAD. PART OF
THE RESULT TAKEN BY SOME
REMEMBER BROKEN TWELVE OR THREE
PROVIDES FOR A REDUCTION IN THE
COOLING OFF PERIOD. FOR FORMER
ASSESSOR EMPLOYEES FROM THREE
YEARS TO ONE YEAR WHICH IS MUCH
MORE COMMON- WAITING PERIOD
FORMER GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES.
BOB THIS IS A SINGLE YEAR TO
COOPER- ALIGNS WITH ALMOST
EVERY OTHER- POST EMPLOYMENT
RESTRICTIONS. I AM UNAWARE OF
ANY ARGUMENT THAT SURE DOES
SINGLE OUT APPRAISERS FOR LIKE
THE RECORD OFF PERIODS. OTHER
REPLY TO OTHER GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES. I UNDERSTAND AND
TAKE TO HEART THE CONCERT OF
TAXPAYER ORGANIZATIONS HOWEVER
RECRUITMENT OF SUFFICIENT
ASSESSMENT PEELS BOARD MEMBERS
IN THE COUNTY. HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
THE SHEER ENORMITY OF THE
WORKLOAD L. A. COUNTY. THE
VOLUMES HEARINGS RECORDED
NINETEEN AND ANTICIPATED
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN WILL CAUSE
BECAUSE- COMPEL US TO TAKE THIS
ACTION. AND TWELVE OR THREE
WILL SERVE AS AN IMPORTANT
TOOL- OF ONE OF ONE TOOL OF
MANY IN HELPING US ADDRESS
THOSE STRUCTURAL DEFICIENCIES.
ADDITIONALLY IF THERE ARE OTHER
CAUSES FOR CONCERN REGARDING A
BOARD MEMBERS PURCHASE A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST. S. IS BUT
STATED THERE ARE AMPLE RULES
AND PROCEDURES. CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE IN THE REVENUE
TAXATION CODE. AS WELL IN THE
COUNTIES ASSESSMENT APPEALS
BOARD MANUAL WHICH ADDRESSES
BUYERS. AND PROVIDE FOR FAIR
AND EQUITABLE HEARINGS OR
TAXPAYERS. GIVEN THE HEAVY
VOLUME OF APPEALS THAT HAVE
OVERWHELMED THE CURRENT
CAPACITY OF THE PROCESS OF L.
A. COUNTY. I BELIEVE THAT AB
TWELVE THREE IS A MUCH NEEDED
PART OF THE REMEDY. AND I URGE
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. IF THE M.
MONTEREY WOULD NOW PLEASE OF UP
THE MAIN LINE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTING TESTIMONY.
IS THERE ANYBODY. WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT VIA REMOTE
VIDEO STATION AT THIS TIME. ANY
OTHER SUPPORT. OKAY. I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WITH THE MODERATE PLEASE
CONNECT US WITH SEAN KELLY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
TAXPAYERS ADVOCATES. YES MADAM
CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR YES. IN HERE
MISTER BANKS HERE- AND GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MY NAME IS JOHN KELLY I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF DEEPEST
QUALITY KELLY AND COMPANY OF
PROP PROPERTY TAX ADVOCACY FIRM
I'M NOT FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF TAXPAYER
ADVOCATES ARE KEITA A STATEWIDE
TRADE ASSOCIATION PER PROPERTY
TAX CONSULTANTS. IN MY TWENTY
FIVE YEARS EXPERIENCE EVER
RESOLVED WELL OVER TWO THOUSAND
APPEALS AND L. A. COUNTY ALONE.
ON BEHALF OF CANADA I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TWELVE
OH THREE. LIKE ALL RESPONSIBLE
INTERESTED PARTIES WE SPEAK THE
ORDERLY AND TIMELY PROCESSING
SHARING AND DISPOSITION OF
ASSESSMENT APPEALS HOWEVER AB
TWELVE R. THREE IS REDUCTION OF
THE COOLING OFF PERIOD FROM
THREE YEARS TO ONE. WELL FAILED
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT IT
TAKES TO RESOLVE. AB TWELVE OH
THREE SIX TO AMEND SENATE BILLS
SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT AND NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN MEASURE WHICH
ACCORDING TO ITS LEGISLATIVE
HISTORY QUOTE ADDED PROVISIONS
TO ENSURE OBJECTIVITY OF
APPEALS BOARD MEMBERS. ON
QUOTE. THE NEED TO ENSURE
OBJECTIVITY IS AS TRUE TODAY AS
IT WAS WITH A- WHEN INTO BY THE
LEGISLATURE A TAXPAYERS CONTEST
OF AN ASSESSMENT WAS DESIGNATED
TO BE RESOLVED WITHIN TWO AND A
HALF YEARS OF THE GENERAL THAT.
THE THREE YEAR PERIOD ACCOUNTED
FOR ANY APPEARANCE OF A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST AB TWELVE
R. THREE WOULD REOPEN THE
DEBATE CREEK TAXPAYERS. KEITA'S
CAREFULLY CONSIDER THE PROBLEMS
IN L. A. COUNTY AND THEN OUR
OPPOSITION LETTER HAS PROVIDED
NINE RECOMMENDATIONS SOME OF
WHICH ARE SUCCESSFULLY USED BY
OTHER COUNTY. IN AN EFFORT TO
FIND A MUTUALLY ACCEPTABLE
RESOLUTION OF THESE PROBLEMS WE%
REQUESTED A MEETING WITH L. A.
COUNTY. WE ASK WHY IS L. A.
COUNTY BRINGING A BILL TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN THEY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS THROUGH ALTERNATIVE
MEANS SO AS LONG AS TWELVE OH
THREE UNDERMINE. THE
OBJECTIVITY OF ASSESSMENT
APPEALS BOARDS WE MUST REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE AND.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NOSE
UP. THANK YOU MISTER KELLY NOW-
WITH THE MODERATE PLEASE HELP
CONNECT THIS TO MISTER SCOTT
KAUFMAN WITH THE HOVER JOBBERS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION. HELLO
THIS IS SCOTT CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN. OKAY WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME GOOD
AFTERNOON I'LL GET STARTED-
CURRENT LOG THIS TO QUOTE
ENSURE OBJECTIVE OBJECTIVE THE
APPEALS BOARD MEMBERS ON QUOTE
CHANGING THOSE RULES ARE A
CONCERN FOR TAXPAYERS AND A
CONCERN FOR THE ASSESSMENT
APPEALS PROCESS. EXISTING LAW
TO QUALIFY THE PERSON FROM
POINT INTO AN ASSESSMENT
APPEALS BOARD IF THE PERSON HAS
WEAKENED IMMEDIATELY PRECEDING
THEIR PLAN TO THE BOARD AN
EMPLOYEE OF THE ASSESSOR'S
OFFICE. THIS BILL WOULD REDUCE
THAT PROHIBITION TO ONE YEAR
AND CREATE A SITUATION WHERE
RECENT CO WORKER TO BE PLACED
IN THE POSITION OF DECIDING THE
OUTCOME OF AN ASSESSMENT APPEAL
OR THEIR FORMER COLLEAGUES
PRESENT UNIFORM AB ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY ASSESSOR. THIS RUN
THE RISK OF BREEDING BY IT AND
UNDERMINING THE INDEPENDENCE OF
AB. THE BILL ALSO SEEKS TO
CHANGE THE MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS OF APPOINTEES IN
AREAS OF EXPERIENCE EDUCATION
CERTIFICATION AND COUNTY WITH A
POPULATION OF TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR MORE. WE BELIEVE
THIS COULD PRODUCE ERRONEOUS
DECISIONS BY AB FOR BOTH THE
ASSESSORS AND TAXPAYERS IT
COULD ALSO DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF APPEALS
OF AB DECISION TO THE COURT IN
ORDER TO CORRECT SUCH RONI
DECISIONS. AT THIS TIME WE
RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
CALL. AT THIS TIME WITH THE
MODERATE PLEASE NOW OPEN THE
MAIN LINE FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. ANYBODY.
IS NOW IS THERE ANY WAY WE CAN
GO AHEAD I'M SORRY. WE HAVE NO
ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION VIA
REMOTE VIDEO STATION AT THIS
TIME. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
YEAH I JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS- I WILL BE VOTING FOR
THIS TODAY I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR TRYING TO SOLVE WHAT
SEEMS TO BE A REAL PROBLEM THAT
CAN INSTALL THEM FOR L. A.
COUNTY AND IT'S JUST IT IS IT'S
AN INTERESTING. ISSUE TO HAVE
LIKE WHAT IS GOING ON IN LA
THAT IS CAUSING THIS SO YOU'VE
GOT PROPERTY OWNERS WHO BELIEVE
THAT THEIR PROPERTIES ARE NOT
ASSESSED ACCURATELY- CORRECTLY
DO NOT REFLECT THE REAL VALUE-
THERE MAY OR MAY NOT BE THAT
MERIT IN THAT FIELD. SO YOU
KNOW THAT'S THAT'S IT AT YOU
KNOW IN ISSUE- AND I JUST FOUND
THAT ASSESSOR'S OFFICES ARE
REALLY THERE TO MAXIMIZE THE
VALUE TO- MAXIMIZE REVENUE TO
THE COUNTY. SO THE COUNTY HAS
THE BUDGET TO PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES AND THE SERVICES THAT
ARE NEEDED THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS
FALL ON THE SIDE OF THE TAX
PAYER WHEN THEY LOOK TO
MAXIMIZE THAT AND SO YOU KNOW I
DO HEAR THE CONCERNS THAT ARE
BEING- STATED- PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE LIKE EVEN IF YOU
WEREN'T THE ONE WHO ASSESSED
THAT PROPERTY THERE ARE A LOT
OF PROPERTIES IN LA. ARE YOU IN
YOU'RE GONNA BE AT LEAST A YEAR
REMOVED YOU MAY BE IN YOU KNOW
A BIT OF A STICKY JAM WHEN
YOU'VE GOT FORMER COLLEAGUE
THAT DID SO OR YOU MAY HAVE A
WORLD VIEW WHERE YOU ARE THERE
TO MAXIMIZE JUST LIKE YOU DID
IN YOUR JOB YOU STILL BELIEVE
THAT YOUR THERE TO MAXIMIZE THE
VALUE OF THAT PROPERTY SAID THE
COUNTY DOES RECEIVE. THAT TAX
REVENUE SO THESE ARE REAL
CONCERNS BUT THAT'S NOT THE
SOLE ISSUE THAT THE BILL IS
TRYING TO SOLVE WHICH IS WE
JUST NEED MORE CAPABLE PEOPLE
TO PROCESS ALL THESE APPEALS SO
I WOULD ENCOURAGE ONE FOR LOS
ANGELES TO BE CAREFUL. ABOUT
HOW THEY- DEVELOP THE NAY. OF
THESE BOARDS I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ONE THERE'S GOING TO BE
MULTIPLE YOU SEEM TO HAVE SO
MANY PROBLEMS AND SO MANY
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE CITY.
HOW DO PEOPLE WITH THE SKILL
SET IN. THE NORTHEAST CORNER OF
THE OF THE COUNTY RATHER. HAVE
ANY SENSE OF WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE SOUTHWEST PART OF THE
COUNTY AND HOW DO YOU PROPERLY-
I PRAISE- AND THEN ASSESS-
THESE PROPERTIES WHEN THEY'RE
SO COMPLETELY DIFFERENT- SO I
DON'T KNOW HOW HE'S GOING TO DO
IT- BUT BE MINDFUL THAT WHEN
YOU CREATE THOSE. MEMBERSHIPS
THAT- YOU REALLY DO WANT THEM.
TO BE OBJECTIVE. IN NOT BE
STACKED ON. THE SIDE OF ANYBODY
BUT IN A WAY THAT THEY CAN
OBJECTIVELY- INFORM WHETHER OR
NOT- THE APPEAL IS MERITED
THANK YOU. YOU NEED TO WOULD
YOU LIKE I DON'T KNOW I'LL
ANSWER MAFIA- IT MAY BE BEST
FOR- ONE OF YOUR WITNESSES TO
ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS THIS
QUESTION THERE NINE SUGGESTIONS
HERE ON HOW TO. BETTER RECRUIT
A MEMBERSHIP. IT ALSO SPEED UP
THE PROCESS- AND I WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW IF- THE ASSESSMENT-
PROCESS WILL LUCK TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT ANY OF THESE NINE
SUGGESTIONS OF THE ASSESSOR'S
WILLING TO TAKE A LOOK AT THEM
AND POSSIBLY IMPLEMENT THEM. HI
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS I HAVE A
FEW SAME WITH- DELCO LAST. DID
HE WANT JEFFREY ANSWER THAT DO
YOU DO YOU WANT DANCE NOW DO
YOU WANT I CAN I CAN ANSWER AT
THE END OR IF JEFFREY WANTS TO
ANSWER THAT SORRY THE NEW YORK
ARGENTI BRING LIKE THIS STUFF.
IF YOU WANT IT I THINK. OKAY
MR- PLAYING. FRANK YES THIS IS.
A COUPLE ECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT
TO JUST CORRECT- MISCONCEPTIONS
THE STATEMENT WAS MADE
PREVIOUSLY ASSESSORS ARE NOT
INVOLVED IN REVENUE WE ARE NOT
A REVENUE DEPARTMENT OUR JOB IS
TO APPLY A FAIR AND ACCURATE
VALUE ON A PIECE OF PROPERTY
REVENUE IS NOT A CONSIDERATION
OF HOW WE DO OUR JOB IT IS A BY
PRODUCT OF OUR DUTY US DOING
OUR JOB WE ARE OBLIGATED TO
ASSIGN A VALUE WITH THE VALUE
WAS HIGHER OR LOWER BUT REVENUE
WAS NEVER PART OF OUR OUT. OF
OUR CHARGE THAT'S WHY THE-
REVENUE DEPARTMENT IS SEPARATE
FROM THE ASSESSOR'S. SUCH AS
OFFICE- SO WE DON'T. BYE BYE BY
PUSHING ADDITIONAL VALUE ON A
PIECE OF PROPERTY WE WOULD BE
UNILATERALLY AND ILLEGALLY-
INCREASING TAXES OUTSIDE THE
ABOUT THE LOSS OF OUR WE WERE
VERY WE TAKE THAT VERY
SERIOUSLY ABOUT MAKING CERTAIN
OF OUR OUR VALUES ARE ACCURATE
AND UP AND FAIR. THERE WERE A
NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WERE MADE SOME OF THEM- WE
AGREE WITH SOME OF THEM WE DO
NOT AGREE WITH SOME OF THEM WE
ACTUALLY BELIEVE ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE BUT THE REALITY IS THAT
THE VOLUME OF CASES- OURS IS SO
SIGNIFICANT IT MAKES SENSE THAT
MAKES MANEUVERABILITY TO
ADDRESS A LOT OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS. VERY VERY VERY
DIFFICULT WE ARE HANDLING-
CASES ON A JUST IN TIME
DELIVERY BECAUSE THE NUMBER
THAT COME UP- THAT ARE A BETTER
SCHEDULE FOR HEARINGS- MY GOAL
IS TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
CASES SO THAT WE CAN SPEND MORE
TIME. WITH EACH TAXPAYER TO
RESOLVE THEIR ISSUES
ADMINISTRATIVELY IF POSSIBLE
PRIOR TO A HEARING AT THE
MOMENT.WE'RE SIMPLY UNABLE TO
DO THAT. OKAY THANK YOU VERY.
MATTER I'LL BE SUPPORTING.
THANK YOU. PLEASE THE HAS SOME
NICE SO BUTTON. JUST REALLY
STARTED DIGGING INTO THIS- THIS
THIS MORNING. AND IT SEEMS TO
BE THAT THE ONE STICKING POINT.
IS IN THIS THREE YEAR VERSUS
ONE YEAR. AND I'M I'M
STRUGGLING WITH THIS A LITTLE
BIT ACTUALLY- NOT ONLY DID I
CALL BOTH OF MINE THE ASSESSORS
IN BOTH RIVERSIDE AND SAN
MARINO COUNTER TO GET THEIR
THOUGHTS ACTUALLY- CALLED SOME
STAFF MEMBERS AT THE FIND OUT
NOW THAT WE'RE TO THE
ASSESSOR'S OFFICE THAT I'VE
KNOWN TO ASK WHAT THEIR
THOUGHTS WERE ON ON THE MATTER
THAT IF THEY- WERE GOING TO
RETIRE FROM- THE- THE COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S OFFICE AND THEN GO
BACK TO WANT TO BE ON. THESE
APPEALS BOARD- AND BOTH OF THEM
HAD SAID BUT NO WAY AM I GOING
TO GO BACK AFTER I'M RETIRED
I'M DONE THERE'S NO WAY I'M TO
GO BACK AND WORK- AND TO BE ON
THE BILL'S BOREDOM WHEN I'M
DONE I'M I'M DONE. BUT IT BUT
IT DID IT WAS INTERESTING AND
IN THIS CONVERSATION THAT I.
THAT THAT I HAD. IS AND I WANNA
LOVE- ACTUALLY REITERATE WHAT
THE GENTLEMAN SAID REPRESENTING
THE ASSESSORS IS THAT. MY TWO
ASSESSORS ABOUT RIVERSIDE. AND
SAMBAR DINO COUNTY I CAN
ASSURE. EVERYONE THAT'S IF IT'S
HERE AND THOSE THAT ARE
LISTENING. THAT THEY ARE NOT
INTERESTED IN INCREASING THEIR
BOTH A VERY CONSERVATIVE ARE
NOT INTERESTED IN INCREASING.
OUR REVENUE A TO THE COUNTY
THEIR JOB IS TO BE ABLE TO
APPLY. THE LAW AND WHEN THEIR
APPEALS THAT COME BEFORE THESE
APPEAL BOARDS. THE GOAL IS TO
TRY TO MAKE SURE TO- APPLY THE
LAW THE PROBLEM IS THE LAW CAN
BE VERY COMPLEX AND
COMPLICATED. AND PEOPLE THAT
ARE APPOINTED TO THESE BOARDS
DON'T REALLY FULLY UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THE LAW. MIGHT BE. AND SO
THERE IS A BENEFIT TO HAVING
FORMER EMPLOYEES WHO UNDERSTAND
THE LAW WHO MIGHT WANT TO
SERVE. TO SIT ON THESE BOARDS
TO MAKE SURE TO PROPERLY APPLY.
THE LAW. WHAT I'M STRUGGLING
WITH IS IN THE OPPOSITION THEY
WERE SAYING WERE FOR GOING TO
BRING ALLOW THESE- FORMER
RETIREES TO SERVE. IF UP. AFTER
THREE YEARS BUT GOING FROM
THREE YEARS TO ONE YEAR. THAT
SEEMS TO BE THAT THE BETTER
STILL WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THREE YEARS
OR ONE YEAR THEY'RE STILL
THEY'RE STILL ABLE TO. TO
SERVE. AND SO IF I CAN HAVE
SOMEBODY FOM THE OPPOSITION
TALK ABOUT. THAT BECAUSE I'M
REALLY STRUGGLING WITH. IF
WE'RE ALLOWING THEM AT ALL. THE
ARGUMENT SHOULD BE THEY SHOULD
BE ABLE TO SERVE. BUT. IS MR
KELLY OR MR KAUFMAN. ON THE
PHONE. THEY CAN ANSWER THIS
QUESTION YES. HI I AM AND I
THINK I CAN ADDRESS THE ISSUE-
SPECIFICALLY- I'M SO THEY DON'T
KNOW WHO YOU ARE. MAYBE IT WAS
STATE YOUR- JOHN KELLY THANK
YOU SHOT. GO AHEAD SORRY ABOUT
THAT- YES I BELIEVE THE ISSUE
THAT WE HAVE IS THAT THERE IS
THERE ISN'T. ANY ISSUE OF
WHETHER OR NOT THERE IS BIAS
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER. BUT THE WAY
THAT THE REVENUE AND TAXATION
CODE WORKS IS THAT AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE MAIN. AND
THEN THERE A TWO STATUTE FOR
RESOLVING ASSESSMENT THEREFORE
THE THREE YEARS MAKES SENSE AS
A COOLING OFF PERIOD. AS THE
STATUTE READ IT IS RESOLVED NOW
THE LEGAL DATE- THE VALUATION
DATE WOULD BE JANUARY FIRST.
AND THEORETICALLY AN ASSESSOR
COULD LEAD HIM THAT SAME DAY
AND THEN IT HERE. HIS OR HER
OWN CASE. SO THAT THE REASON
WHY THE THREE YEAR PERIOD IT
WAS INCORPORATED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE I'M SORRY SAID
THEORETICALLY CAN YOU THE- GET
WHAT WHAT DO YOU MEAN IN THEORY
BECAUSE THERE IT'S AN EASY FIX
WE HAVE THE PARTS OF AMAZING
WHAT WE CAN DO HERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY PUT LANGUAGE IN BILLS
AND FIX THAT ABOUT THIRTY IN
LIKE THAT'S THAT IF THAT'S IF
THAT'S THE CASE- SO. WHAT WHAT
DO YOU MEAN BY THEORETICALLY.
WHEN THE ORIGINAL NINETEEN
FIFTY SEVEN LEGISLATION WAS PUT
IN PLACE. THERE WAS A SIX MONTH
TIME PERIOD BETWEEN VALUATION
AND APPEAL. AND THEN THERE WAS
A TWO YEAR PERIOD WHERE THOSE
APPEALS WOULD BE RESOLVED.
WHICH IS WHY THE THREE YEAR
PERIOD WAS PUT INTO PLACE AT
THE BEGINNING. NOW WE HAVE AN
ISSUE WHERE A SITTING ASSESSOR.
AND WITH ALL DUE. RESPECT IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY THAT THEY'RE
BIASED IT'S JUST WHETHER OR NOT
THEY COULD SET. AND RESOLVE THE
CASE THAT THEY WERE EITHER
APPROVED FOR OR A SUPERVISOR-
OR- IN THAT SAME GROUP BUT NOT
WHAT THAT'S WHAT THAT'S THE
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE. OKAY IT.
TELL ME ANSWER THE QUESTION IS
A XIN- BUT I WOULD LOVE TO BE
ABLE TO HEAR FROM THE AUTHOR
ONLY SO WE HAVE GONE TO LEDGE%
COUNCIL WE HAVE AN ORAL OPINION
FROM LEAD COUNSEL AND THAT AND
FORMER EMPLOYEE CANNOTYOUR
CASE THAT THEY HAVE WORKED ON
ONE PLATE IT'S JUST IT'S
ALREADY IN LIFE IN COMMON LAW
SO THIS NOTION THAT THAT CAN
HAPPEN IS. UNFORTUNATELY I
LISTEN I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
ARE THOSE WHO HAPPEN IF YOU
WAITED THE SYSTEM OVER THE
YEARS BECAUSE OF THE
OVERWHELMING SYSTEM IT WAS
EASIER TO MANIPULATE THE
APPEALS PROCESS IT IS VERY
TIMELY PROCESS AND SO I GET
THAT THERE'S OPPOSITION THAT
DOES NOT WANT THERE TO BE MORE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE BILLS
ACTUALLY TO BE PROCESSED ON
TIME BECAUSE THE AUTOMATIC
DEFAULT IS IF THEY'RE NOT
PROCESSING TIME THEN THEY WIN
THEIR APPEAL. SO I GET ALL THAT
BUT THE REALITY BUT TO CONTINUE
TO IS TO SAY THAT FORMER
EMPLOYEES CAN WORK ON THESE
CASES IT'S JUST NOT THE LAW THE
LAW SAYS OPPOSITE AND WE CAN WE
HEAR AN COLLEGE COUNCIL IF WE
NEED IT BUT WE WENT AND GOT IF
THEIR WORK IF THAT WAS NOT
ALREADY LAW I GUARANTEE YOU WE
WOULD ADD IT TO THE BILL I
DON'T WANT I WANT THE PROCESS
TO BE FAIR I WANT THE PROCESS
TO HAVE MERIT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SAID SOME APPEALS HAVE MERIT
SOME DON'T AND I WANT THE
PROCESS TO BE. TO BE WELL
EXECUTED IN L. A. COUNTY
THERE'S A REASON THIS IS
SPECIFIC L. A. COUNTY WE'RE
SEEING A HUGE INFLUX BUT THERE
ARE THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
GAIN THE SYSTEM BASED ON THE
INEQUITY OF THE INEFFICIENCY OF
THE SYSTEM RIGHT NOW WITH SO
FEW PEOPLE. KNOW OTHER
SITUATION CALLS FOR A THREE
YEAR COOLING OFF PERIOD NOT OUR
OWN NOT THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
THREE YEARS IS AN EXTREMELY
LONG COOLING OFF PERIOD AND
WITH ALREADY IN PLACE LAW THAT
YOU CANNOT HEAR CASES THAT YOU
HAVE WORKED ON I'M I AND MY
FRUSTRATION IS THE CONTINUING
USE OF THAT RHETORIC WITHOUT
ANY BASIS IN LAW OR FACT. SO IF
SOMEONE WANTS TO SHOW. ME WHERE
LEAD COUNSEL IS WRONG I HAPPILY
ADD TO THIS BILL. THAT THAT NOT
BE A. MADAM CHAIR IF I MAY AND
I KNOW YOU HAVE A CAR WOULD AND
I WILL THIS SINCE YOU SAID THAT
THERE'S YOU HAVE A LEAD COUNSEL
OPINION WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO
MAKE THAT PUBLIC IF IT'S AN
ORAL PAIN YOU CAN COLLEGE
COUNCIL YOURSELF BUT IT'S IN
OUR OPINION THAT IT'S AN KICKED
IN IF YOU COULD AND IF ANYONE
AND EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM COULD
TAKE ME AT MY WORD. THAT IF IN
FACT THEY FIND THAT THAT IS NOT
THE ACTUAL LAW AND THAT LET'S
COUNCIL IS WRONG. THEN LET ME
KNOW WHEN WE'LL PUT IT IN THE
BILL BUT IT'S JUST IT'S
REPETITIVE TO PUT IN THE BILL
AT THIS POINT BECAUSE IT'S NOT
ALLOWED. IT'S COMMON LAW IT'S
NOT ALLOWED. THE I WILL- I'LL
ASK I'LL I'LL GO ASK THE
COUNCILS THAT'S ONE OF MY
CONCERN AS WELL AS- IT'S JUST
IT'S JUST IT'S MORE OF THE-
IT'S- AND IN ONE OF THE
CONCERN. THAT I HAVE MAINLY IS
IT'S A THREE YEAR PERIOD. THE I
GUESS IS FROM THE TAX PAYER
SIDE. KNOWING THAT MAYBE A IN
THE PRAISE A SPECIALIST WHO
WORKED ON MY CASE. AND THEN A
YEAR LATER IS LEAD. INTO THE
OUT OVERSEE MY APPEAL I THINK
WOULD MAKE ME VERY NERVOUS. OR
DEPRESSED THE APPRAISER-
SPECIALIST- OR FORMER EMPLOYEES
NOW ON THE APPEAL. WHO IS VERY
CLOSE TO. YOU KNOW OR PARTNER
WITH ANOTHER APPRAISER
SPECIALIST SUPERVISOR- THAT.
NOW IS OVERSEE MY CASE THAT
WOULD MAKE ME NERVOUS AS A
TAXPAYER I THINK THAT'S WHERE
THE ONE PERIOD THREE PERIOD
MAKES PEOPLENERVOUS AND- I OF
ALL BE HAVE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
REACH OUT TO THAT COUNCIL IN
THE ANNOUNCEMENT OPINION AND IF
SO- AND I APPRECIATE YOUR-
WILLINGNESS TO YOU KNOW FIX
THAT ISSUE IF THAT IS THE CASE
YEAH NO ABSOLUTELY LET'S AND WE
WANT THE SYSTEM TO WORK AND WE
WANT IT TO WORK WELL. AND IT
OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T WORK WELL IF
THERE'S ANY SORT OF BIAS
HOWEVER THREE YEARS IS NOT IS
NOT GET NECESSARY TO HAVE IT BE
THREE YEARS TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S NO BIAS QUITE FRANKLY
EVEN IN A YEAR AT THERE THERE
THEY MAY HAVE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THOSE WHO HAVE COME ON TO
THE BOARD I MEAN THAT'S JUST.
THERE IN THE SAME BUSINESS
RIGHT SO ONE YEARS THREE YEARS
IT'S NOT THAT IS NOT GONNA MAKE
A DIFFERENCE HOWEVER I WILL
ATTEST THAT IF FOR WHATEVER
REASON ANYBODY FINDS THAT IT IS
NOT. THAT YOU MUST RECUSE
YOURSELF OR THAT A FORMER
EMPLOYEE CANNOT HEAR THESE
CASES. IT WILL BE PUT IN THE
BILL OKAY THANK YOU. MEDICINE
WOMAN PLEASE. YEAH SERVICE TWO
QUESTIONS FOR THE ASSESSOR'S
OFFICE- IT IS NUMBER ONE AM I
CORRECT IN UNDERSTANDING THAT
LA. OF CALIFORNIA'S COUNTIES
THESE KIND OF UNIQUELY
OVERWHELMED BY APPEALS AND- I
INSUFFICIENT CAPACITY TO
PROCESS THOSE. AND NUMBER TWO-
IN ADDITION TO GETTING THIS-
YEAH THIS LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY
TO THIS LEGISLATIVE FIX. ARE
YOU ALSO EVALUATING BEST
PRACTICES AND EFFECTIVE PROCESS
SEES THAT HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED
IN OTHER CALIFORNIA COUNTIES TO
ENSURE THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH A PROCESS THAT IT'S
EFFECTIVE AND A SWIFT FOR
TAXPAYERS. YES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YES. YES WE ARE
EVALUATING OTHER OUT BEST
PRACTICES IS THIS MULTIPLE
THING THANK. YEAH IF POSSIBLE
ALL THE SPEAKERS BECAUSE WE
DON'T SEE YOUR FACE IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL IF YOU JUST LET US KNOW
WHO YOU ARE AT THE BEGINNING
THANK YOU. MY APOLOGIES AGAIN
THIS IS A ASSESSOR JEFFREY
PRANG L. L. A. COUNTY SO ONE-
THE FIRST QUESTION WAS- ARE WE
GOING TO BE OVERWHELMED THE
TRUTH IS WE'RE OVERWHELMED AND
NOW WE ARE STILL PROCESSING
BACKLOGS FROM THE RECESSION OF
200-082-2000 TEN PROBABLY ONE
OF THE REASONS IS BECAUSE
CERTAIN- TAXPAYER ADVOCATES
HAVE CREATED A SYSTEM THEY GAME
THE SYSTEM THEY'VE CREATED A
WAY TO MONETIZE THE SYSTEM
WHICH RESULTS IN HAVING
LITERALLY. THOUSANDS UPON
THOUSANDS OF PEELS FILED
ANNUALLY OF WHICH THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE WITHOUT
MERIT ARE ULTIMATELY WITHDRAWN
BUT CONSUMING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN PERSONNEL HOURS AND-
IN DELAYING MORE MERITORIOUS
CASES ON ANNUAL BASIS- WE DO WE
ARE WE ARE EXPLORING AND WOULD
HAVE WILL IMPLEMENT ANYTHING
THAT WE CAN DO TO MAKE THE
SYSTEM WORK BETTER. AND MORE
EXPEDIENT WAY WHICH IS WHY
WE'RE SUPPORTING IT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE OH THREE HAVING
SUFFICIENT NUMBERS OF QUALIFIED
BOARD MEMBERS TO ENSURE THAT
THESE THE CURRENT SIX SOON TO
BE SEVEN SEVEN APPEALS BOARDS
CAN MEET EVERY DAY TO HANDLE
THIS- BOB THIS BACKLOG WILL BE
CRITICAL TO REDUCING THOSE OUT
THOSE BACKLOGS THERE ARE OTHER
THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE BUT-
BUT IN REALITY WE NEED TO GET
THIS BACKLOG DOWN BY ABOUT 50%
BEFORE WE CAN START REALLY
HAVING A LOT OF
MANEUVERABILITY. TO IMPLEMENT-
OTHER STRATEGIES MADAM CHAIR OF
MEMBERS I APOLOGIZE TO
INTERJECT THIS IS JEREMY GREAT
REPRESENTING THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICE OF BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND- I THINK ASSESSOR PRANG IS
DOING TO- BUT EXCELLENT JOB
HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING- AS A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION FOR THE BODY OF
THE ASSESSMENT APPEALS BOARD IT.
IN FACT INDEPENDENT FROM THE-
OFFICE AND THEY ARE POINT BY
LOCAL. BOARD OF SOME. AND
OVERSEEN BY THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICE OF THE BOARD OF WHICH
I'M HERE REPRESENTING TODAY AND
I WOULD LIKE TO AGREE WITH- THE
ASSESSOR- AND- JUST HIGHLIGHT
JUST VARIOUS THINGS THAT WE ARE
DOING TO ADDRESS THE QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY. WITHIN L. A.
COUNTY WE REALIZED THAT THE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL IS NOT
A PANACEA IT IT IS NOT. OF A
SINGULAR FOCUS FOR US AND WE
ARE DOING MANY OTHER THINGS TO
NOT ONLY REALIZE ADDITIONAL
EFFICIENCIES WITHIN OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT- RELATED TO
TECHNOLOGY ADVANCEMENTS. ARE
STREAMLINING PROCESS SEES-
SCHEDULING- ETCETERA- BUT BUT
BUT IS IDENTIFIED BY OUR
ASSESSOR. WHAT WHAT AB TWELVE
ALL THREE ACTUALLY DOES FOR US
IS IT WIDENS THE CANDIDATE POOL
FOR OUR BOARD. TO APPOINT
QUALIFIED MEMBERS AND BEER BY
INCREASES OUR CAPACITY TO TAKE
ON ADDITIONAL HEARINGS AND
ENSURE THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS
RECEIVE FAIR AND UNBIASED.
RULINGS OUT OF. SIGHT AND I
KNOW I DO UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT
THE BILL DOES MIGHT MY QUESTION.
ORIGINALLY WAS. BECAUSE IT
SEEMS LIKE WHAT'S BEEN JUST THE
L. A. COUNTY IT HAS FOUND
ITSELF. OVERWHELMED BY THIS
ISSUE AND IF THAT IS IN FACT
THE CASE I THINK HM IT'S KIND
OF THIS AND I'M SUPPORT
INVOLVED BUT IT'S DISINGENUOUS
TO SUGGEST THAT IT IS. THE
FAULT OF TAX PAYER
ORGANIZATIONS OR INDIVIDUAL TAX
PAYERS GAMING THE SYSTEM WHEN
OTHER COUNTIES- MANAGING TO DO
TO DEAL WITH THIS EFFECTIVELY
WHICH TO MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THEY ARE SO- I GUESS I WOULD
SERVE CHALLENGE THAT AS A CORE
PROMISE AND THE CHALLENGE ALSO
IN ADDITION TO. EXPANDING THE
POOL OF ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS TO
PURSUE SOME OTHER STRATEGIES
TO- TO RECTIFY THE ISSUES THAT
YOU'RE GONNA PLAN BY THREE AND
FOR CLARIFICATION PURPOSES
OTHER COUNTIES ARE STRUGGLING
WITH THIS WE JUST MADE THIS
JUST FOR L. A. COUNTY AND AT
SOME POINT OTHER COUNTY'S NAME
ON IT BUT RIGHT NOW I'M NOT. SO.
OTHER COUNTIES ARE. I IT OKAY
THANK YOU TO THE CHECK. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS I'VE GOT A
COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR ME- MADAM
CHAIR FOR YOURSELF OR- THE
ASSESSOR RDM CEO OF L. A.
COUNTY- FIRST QUESTION HOW MANY
FORMER SISTER PERSONNEL MEET
THE ONE YOUR REQUIREMENT VERSUS
THE THREE YEAR REQUIREMENTS
DON'T DO YOU KNOW. SECOND
QUESTION IS- HAVEN'T BEEN A
FORMER COUNTY SUPERVISOR I KNOW
NOT IN LOS ANGELES BUT IN
ORANGE COUNTY- NEXT DOOR- WHEN
WE HAD PROBLEMS WITH
RECRUITING- CANDIDATES FOR
ASSESSMENT HE WAS BORED BECAUSE
EACH SUPERVISOR IN OUR COUNTY.
HAS CERTAIN NUMBERS OF- CAN'T I
MEAN CERTAIN OF APPOINTMENTS
THAT WE APPOINT. OR RECOMMENDED
TO BE APPOINTED. THE WE WOULD
ALL GO OUT DIFFERENT METHODS OF
TRYING TO DO RECRUITMENT. HAS
L. A. COUNTY. LOOKED INTO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF METHODS IN
TERMS OF RECRUITMENT OR IS
THERE IF YOU'VE EXHAUSTED
EVERYTHING EVERY IDEA POSSIBLE
TO FIND YOU KNOW BECAUSE I MEAN
YOU'VE GOT TEN MILLION PEOPLE
IN THAT COUNTY IS A LOT OF
PEOPLE. IT'S NOT LIKE ORANGE
COUNTY WE HAVE ONLY THREE POINT
TWO MILLION PEOPLE- SO THIS GUY
BE ABLE BODIES OR WHAT ARE WE
MISSING HERE- THAT. I'M NOT
SEEING OR- OR THERE ISN'T
ANYTHING. MISTER THIS IS A
ASSESSOR JEFF CRYING SO I CAN'T
SPEAK- TO THE- THE BROADER
RECRUITMENT OF APPEALS BOARD
MEMBERS THAT COMES UNDER THE
PURVIEW OF THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICE- I CAN SAY THAT- YEAH WE
THE ASSESSOR'S OFFICE- TRIPS
ABOUT- BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE AND
THIRTY FIVE. RAISERS ANNUALLY
DUE TO RETIREMENTS. I DON'T
HAVE AN EXACT NUMBER OF THE OF
WRITTEN RETIRES WHO WOULD FIT
INTO THE POOL- POTENTIAL
CANDIDATES TO BE AN ASSESSMENT
FEEL BORED I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOWEVER THAT THE LAST FORTY
YEARS- WE- ONLY KNOW IT HAD
IDENTIFIED. THREE THEFORMER
ASSESSOR PLAYS WHO WENT ON TO
SERVE ON THE SYSTEM THE PEEL
BOARD SO I'M NOT EXPECTING THAT
THERE'D BE A- HUGE INFLUX OF
NEW- NEW CANDIDATES WHO JUST.
SHORTEN THE PERIOD UP. A LITTLE
BIT AND I'M SORRY SOMETHING
NUMBER US THREE QUESTIONS I
CAN'T RECALL THE- I'M JUST LAST
DAY. DOES TOO IS THE C. E. O.
ON. YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK
YOU- JEREMY GREAT CHIEF DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICE OF THE BOARD-
IN RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTION
EACH OF OUR BOARD OFFICES ARE
ALL RESPONSIBLE FOR IDENTIFYING
AND APPOINTING- ASSESSMENT
APPEALS BOARD MEMBERS AND THE
ERROR MESSAGE WILL RANGE
ANYWHERE FROM- REACHING OUT TO
THE EXISTING CONTACTS THAT THEY
HAVE- WITHIN ALL REAL ESTATE
SECTORS- ADDITIONALLY THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICE ASSIST. IN
FACILITATING THE RECRUITMENT OF
QUALIFIED- BOARD MEMBERS-
THROUGH WEBSITE SOLICITATION
SOCIAL MEDIA- ETCETERA SO WE GO
THROUGH A VERY RIGOROUS PROCESS
NOT ONLY FOR- OUR BOARD MEMBERS
BUT ARE HEARING OFFICERS TO-
RECRUIT- QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS.
THANK YOU- A- MADAM CHAIR I AM
I UNDERSTAND YOU WOULD BE
SECOND A TECHNICAL AMENDMENT
YOU NOTED EARLIER WHAT IS THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- I
THINK IT'S ALL BEEN SAID. WITH
A RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS IN A
HOTEL. I KNOW WE HAD A MOTION
TO MY RIGHT. AND THEN I HAD A
SECOND TO MY LEFT CIRCUITING
WAS IT. OKAY- WHAT THAT CAN SO
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED. MISTER WOLF WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BURKE HI
BURKE AT FIVE WHEN NO WHEN NO
GREAT. GRAYSON HI GRAYSON HI
LEVINE. MAYES MAYES FIVE MULLIN.
ABSENT PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS FIVE CORK I
WORKED FIVE THREE OF US. THEY
ARE. TO AND WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
THE ROAD OPEN. FIVE OAKS WE'LL
KEEP THAT OPEN THANK YOU MA'AM-
I SEE IT ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIVING
A LETTER TO FILE ITEM THREE AB
TEN SIXTY FIVE MAIENSCHEIN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN YOU'RE
READY. AB TEN SIXTY FIVE CRATES
THE MENTAL HEALTH HELP PROGRAM
IN ALLOWS TAXPAYERS TO MAKE
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTIONS ON
THEIR TECH CALIFORNIA TAX
RETURNS TO ENABLE THE BILL. IN
LIGHT OF THAT TABLE. CUT ON MY
I KNOW I KNOW I KNOW MIGHT
DISAPPOINT YOU MISTER MAYES.
THIS PROGRAM GIVES OFFICERS
IMPORTANT TOOLS TO PERFORM
THEIR JOB SAFELY AND
EFFECTIVELY WHILE HELPING TO
KEEP PEOPLE LIVING WITH A
MENTAL ILLNESS OUT OF JAIL OFF
THE STREETS ENROLLED IN
TREATMENT. AND ON THE ROAD TO
RECOVERY. I THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I FELT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
UNDERSTAND THEIR TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WITH THE
MODERATOR PLEASE CONNECT US
WITH CAROLE TURNER OF NANNY
CALIFORNIA. ONE MOMENT. THE
TERM YOUR LINE IS OPEN SIR.
OKAY I'M READY THANK YOU SO
MUCH- AGAIN I'M CAROLE TURNER
AND THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
NAMI URBAN LOS ANGELES. AND I
WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF. AB
TEN SIXTY FIVE THIS IS A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA TO HELP
SUPPORT A REALLY WORTHWHILE
ISSUE LEAVE A CRITICAL ISSUE AT
THIS POINT. IS FOR- TO BE I. T.
TRAINING. AND OUR POLICE FORCES
REALLY STRETCHED TO THE LIMITS
RIGHT NOW AND- TRAINING IS VERY
NECESSARY WE'VE WE'VE ALWAYS
NEEDED BADLY NEEDED MORE BUT-
IT'S BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND THE EXPLOSION OF
MENTAL HEALTH CALLS THAT HAVE
BEEN COMING IN TO THE POLICE.
THAT WE HERE AT NAMI URBAN LOS
ANGELES BEYOND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY I HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH- YOU KNOW OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE AND WE NEED
TO. ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS TO
EXPAND THE WORK THAT WE DO WITH
THEM. SO THAT- WE CAN READ
DEUCE THE- OUR NEGATIVE
OUTCOMES ARE ALL TOO PREVALENT
IN THESE INTERSECTIONS OF BUT
MENTAL HEALTH AND- AND- I WILL
JUSTICE CALLS. SO WE WOULD
ABSOLUTELY MEDIA IS COMMITTED
TO. REALLY THE THAT THIS
PROGRAM- IS- IS EXTENDED AND
THAT NAMI CALIFORNIA IS A
INCLUDED ON THE LIST OF
ELIGIBLE ORGANIZATIONS- WE RELY
ON THEM A LOT IN. IN THE IN OUR
COMMUNITY IRVING- SOUTH SOUTH
CENTRAL SOUTHWEST LOS ANGELES-
BE ABLE TO. GET THE RESOURCES
THAT WE NEED TO ENTER ACT WITH
THE POLICE AND START THAT
COMMUNICATION THAT'S SO
ESSENTIAL BETWEEN PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND THE POLICE. AND-
DOES TRAINING CURRICULUMS AGAIN
AS I SAY ARE SO IMPORTANT IN
THE TIMELINE- SO IN COURT IS-
THESE ARE THINGS THAT- WE
REALLY NEEDED TO EXPAND THEIR
CORE WHILE WE WOULD ASK YOU
THAT. THIS TO THE- BILL IS IT
IN FACT MOVED ALONG TO IN APRIL
THE SIMPSONS OF CALIFORNIA TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT APRIL MAY NEED TO DO THAT
FOR INCREASING OUR OUT REACH
WHO- POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND
FIRST RESPONDERS FOR ADDITIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH TRAINING THANK
YOU SIR THANK. THANK YOU AND
I'M OUR NEXT CLUE OUR NEXT
WITNESS WOULD BE AT SHANNON
JACQUARD. AND PLEASE TWO
MINUTES FOR YOUR COMMENTS
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS SAM LICCARDO I WITH THE CEO
OF YOUR MASON DIEGO AND
CURRENTLY THURMOND THE NEW YORK
COUNTY THE EVER HELP LORD AND
IN THE CURRENT BOARD CHAIR OF
OUR INTERNATIONAL IN ANSWERED
AS A MENTAL HEALTH TRAINER.
HOWEVER I'M SPEAKING HERE
TODAY- IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
ZERO SIX FIVE AS IF THERE IS
SOMEBODY WHO IS DIAGNOSED WITH
SCHIZOPHRENIA. AND JUST SHARING
MY TWENTY YEAR HISTORY OF. THE
FAMILY MEMBER AND ADVOCATE.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO I WAS AT NOT
MEETING GUY ACT DID A SEARCH
AND FOUND MEMBERS ON WHETHER OR
NOT THEY'D EVER CALLED THE
POLICE TO SUPPORT THEM AND CARE
FOR THEIR LOVED ONES. AND 95%
HAD SAID YES THEN I ASKED THEM
ONTO THE MAKE THE FIRST CALL TO
THE POLICE. 95% LEAD WITHIN THE
FIRST YEAR OF DIAGNOSIS OR
BEFORE THEY WERE EVEN
DIAGNOSIS. WHICH MEANS THAT
MOST INDIVIDUALS MOST
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
AND THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS BEGIN
THEIR JOURNEY TO MENTAL
WELLNESS. AT WITH THE BEGINNING
OF POLICE INTERACTIONS. OUR
GOAL SHOULD BE THAT THIS IS NOT
THE CASE BUT WE NEED TO
ELIMINATE STIGMA. ENHANCE
CRISIS INTERVENTION SERVICES. I
SO IN THE MEANTIME WE STILL
NEED AT LEAST INTERVENTION FOR
MENTAL HEALTH PRACTICES. WHERE
LIMITING THE SUCCESS OF OUR
OFFICERS IN CREATING TERM AFTER
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
AND THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS BY NOT
HAVING THE ADEQUATE TRAINING.
SO MY BROTHER WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH SCHIZOPHRENIA AT THE AGE
OF NINETEEN HE EXPERIENCED
MOMENTS OF SELF HARM THAT LEFT
OF THE FREIGHT FOR HIM. WE WERE
THE TYPICAL FAMILY THAT DIDN'T
KNOW MUCH ABOUT MENTAL ILLNESS
AND WE WERE FORCED TO YOU KIND
OF LEARN AS WE GO WHICH IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT MOST FAMILY
MEMBERS EXPERIENCE. OUR LIVES
REVOLVED AROUND HIS NEEDS AND
HOSPITAL STAYS. ON ONE OCCASION
MY BROTHER'S BEHAVIOR WITH NO
CONCERNING THAT MY FAMILY FELT
LIKE HE NEEDED. SOME HELP AND
THEY CALLED FOR THE POLICE. THE
INTERACTION THOMAS TO ALL
PARTIES AND MY MOTHER'S
MORTGAGE NEVER CALL THEM AGAIN.
AND WHILE THAT MAY BE A
WONDERFUL GOAL IS. TO BELIEVE
THAT MY BROTHER ILLNESS WHEN GO
ON TO A- ONLINE FOR HERE IN A
CAR. IT TOOL THE TO. MENTAL
ILLNESS TO BE MORE OF A ACOSTA
THAN ONE DIRECTION. AND WE TO
KEEP A THE- TO CALL FROM THE
POLICE IN CRIME OF CRISIS.
PLEASE ENTER VENTURE. REALLY
MUST BE LAST WEEK. AND NOT THE
FIRST CALL IT WILL FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE. TO MAKE. BUT EVEN
WILL RESORT NINETY TO BE AT THE-
IN. TO SUPPORT A IN THE BACK
SHAPE. IN SOMEONE WHO WORKED IN
THE IT. FIFTY I DRINK THE I. T.
AND OTHERS LIKE IT IS ONE TWO
STEP FOR. OUR OFFICERS. NOW IN
OF. X. A MENTAL CRISIS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WITH NOW PLEASE-
OPEN THE MAINLY FOR ANY OF
SUPPORT TESTIMONY. REPUBLICAN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE'S KEYPAD AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER THE SECURE LINE NUMBER
TO BE CALLED WE OPEN YOUR LINE.
FOR YOUR COMMENT AND AT THAT
TIME STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION FOOTBALL
LEGISLATIVE RECORD PLEASE ONE
MOMENT OUR FIRST QUESTION. OUR
FIRST COMMENT.
THE ONE MOMENT
APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY WE
ALMOST.
SEVEN THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE FOR
GOING THE LINE NUMBER FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MATURE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. FOR ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE.
THE TIME WITH NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS COMING UP.
SEND UP
SORRY BUT IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF YOUR REMOTE VIDEO. SEEING
NINE IS THERE ANYONE IN THE- IN
THE HEARING ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SEEING NONE
WITH THE MODERATOR NOW PLEASE
OPEN THE MAINLINE FOR ANY
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. IN A
POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IS THERE ANYONE
OPPOSITION IN THE REMOTE VIDEO
STATION AT THIS TIME. SEEING
NONE ANYONE IN HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE NOTION OF TWIST THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RESPECTED REQUEST AN IPHONE
THANK YOU MISTER IF WE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI. BURKE
I WENT. GREAT GREAT I GRAYSON
HI GRAYSON ALL RIGHT LET ME.
LEVINE I MAYES ALL RIGHT MAYES
AYE MON. MULLIN ABSENT
PETRIE-NORRIS. PETRIE-NORRIS II
CORK AYE QUIRK AYE THREE OF US.
SARTO. BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES THE
BUILD OUT THANK YOU
MEASUREMENTS WITH SOME
COMMUTING TO FILE ITEM FOR AB
EIGHT THIRTY SEVEN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BEGIN. MOVE THE BILL. SECOND
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU FROM ALLOW ME TO PRESENT AB
EIGHT THIRTY SEVEN A MEASURE OF
PERSONAL IMPORTANCE TO ME I
KNOW I SHARE THE SENTIMENT THAT
MEMBERS OF OUR MILITARY DESERVE
OUR UTMOST SUPPORT AND AS THEIR
AS THE SISTER OF A SOLDIER-
SUPPORT FOR VETERANS IS A LONG
TIME PRIORITY OF MINE AND THE
ISSUE WAS BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION OF AN INDIVIDUAL
DEPLOYED OVERSEAS. BEING
FINANCIALLY BLINDSIDED BY A
LIEN PLACED ON THEIR ACCOUNT BY
THE CALIFORNIA FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD THE PRIORITY OF OUR
SOLDIERS SERVING SHOULD NOT BE
A TAX DISPUTE MORE PENALTIES
WHILE THEY ARE RISKING THEIR
LIVES FOR US OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
NOT THE INTENT OF THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD NOT NOR HAS IT EVER
BEEN. THE PROCESS FOR
PROTECTING DEPLOYED INDIVIDUALS
FROM TAX PENALTIES IS AN
EXTENSIVE COORDINATION BETWEEN
F. T. B. AND THE IRS AND THE
TAX PAYER HOWEVER THIS DID NOT
HAPPEN FOR FAMILIES OF DEPLOYED
MEMBERS THIS HAD- THIS HAS A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
FINANCIAL STABILITY AND IT'S
NOT ACCEPTABLE. I COMMIT TO
KEEP ARE WORKING WITH THE F. T.
B. TO DO WE ARE WHO DO NOT HAVE
A POSITION ON THAT THIS MEASURE
TO IMPROVE THIS PROCESS SO IT
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR- VOTE- IF THERE IS ANY.
WITH MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
MAINLINE FOR ANY SUPPORT
TESTIMONY. CERTAINLY WANT TO
GET IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. AND NO COLLEGE KID UP
THANK YOU IS ANYONE IN THE ROOM
A VIDEO GROW STATION AT THIS
TIME NONE. OF ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE
MODERATOR WE OPEN THE LINE FOR
ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY.
MAPUCHE PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO.
WE HAVE NOT A CUTE CREATE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE VIDEO REMOTE
ROOM STATION PLEASE- ANYONE IN
THE ROOM. SEEING NONE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
BURKE PARK- IN THE ANALYSIS IT
SAYS THIS IS ALREADY THE POLICY
SO. WHAT DIFFERENCE DOES THE
BILL MAKE. WELL EVEN THOUGH IT
IS THE POLICY THERE'S SOME FOR-
FOLKS ARE FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS SO MY HOPE IS THAT WE
CAN KEEP WORKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR PROCEDURES ARE
ARE SOLIDIFIED SO IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN EVEN THOUGH IT IS
ACCORDING TO F. OF THE ANALYSIS
AGAIN IT'S TOP AND SOLD MY GOAL
IS TO IDENTIFY. THE REASONS AS
TO WHY IT DID HAPPEN EVEN
THOUGH IT'S ALREADY PART OF THE
PROCEDURE AND- AND WE'VE MADE A
COMMITMENT TO THE AUTHOR THAT
WE WILL KEEP WORKING TO FIND
WHAT THAT TECHNICAL ISSUE IS
THAT ALLOWED IT TO CAN YES
ABSOLUTELY AND AGAIN I THE
INTENT IS THAT- IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN TO TWO OTHER- MILITARY
FAMILIES WHILE THEY'RE DEPLOYED
AGAIN. ON THE ANALYSIS STATES
THAT IT WAS A- THAT IT'S
ALREADY IMPALA BY AGAIN IT HAS
HAPPENED SO. THE GOAL IS TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN EITHER BY. I'M MAKING
SURE THAT THE POLICIES IN THE
PROCEDURES ARE BEING FOLLOWED
OR TO IDENTIFY THE REASON WHY
DID HAPPEN. SO I THINK THERE
ARE BETTER WAYS TO DO THIS ONE
WOULD BE JUST HAPPEN AUDIT.
OKAY I DO NOT THINK THIS IS. I
DON'T THINK THIS IS GOING TO
CHANGE ANYTHING THAT'S MY MAIN
CONCERN- AND I'D MUCH RATHER
YOU DO THIS THROUGH AN AUDIT SO
ALL NOT BE VOTING. I JUST DON'T
THINK THIS IS GOING TO HELP.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE OF
THE- COMICS MISTER CORK- I DO
SIT ON THE ON J. LIKE THE ADDED
ON COMMITTEE AND THAT'S GOING
TO TAKE AN EXTENSIVE AMOUNT I
APPRECIATE THE SUGGESTION. BUT
AGAIN MY INTENT IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT AT LEAST WE ARE
HIDING THE IT HIGHLIGHTING THE
ISSUE AND- I'M COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
IDENTIFY THE TECHNICALITY THAT.
ON THE OR THE REASON THAT LIKE
THIS FLU- WHAT'S THROUGH THE
CRACKS AGAIN. IF IN FACT WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE BILL AND
WE CAN FIX IT THROUGH THE BILL
AND IF WE CAN'T THEN AGAIN I'M
COMMITTED- TO. WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO MAKING SURE THAT
THIS DOES NOT HAPPEN EITHER BY-
MAKING THAT THE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES STRONGER SO BAD.
THAT THE COMMUNICATION IS.
BETTER I GUESS. BECAUSE IT
SEEMS LIKE. IF IT'S AN LAW THEN
SOMETHING DID HAPPEN AND IT
FELL THROUGH THE CRACKS. ALL
RIGHT WELL AS LONG AS YOU'RE
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE. AND
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
CHAIR I WILL VOTE I THANK YOU
BUT I REALLY THINK AN AUDIT
WOULD BE THE BEST. WAY TO FIND
OUT WHAT'S GOING WRONG AND
THEREFORE HOW TO FIX IT I'M
JUST NOT SURE THIS WILL OKAY.
THINKING I'VE- THAT I
APPRECIATE- AND AGAIN I SAID
I'M DONE J. LACK SO I WILL. BE
TALKING TO THE CHAIR ON MISTER
SALAS TO SEE IF THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD ON.
AUDIT THANK YOU. GOOD ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS AND
STUFF- MADAM. ASSEMBLY WOMAN- A
SENTIMENT- KELLY- SEATTLE ISN'T
ABLE TO BE HERE BECAUSE HE'S IN
THE EMERGENCY. MANAGEMENT
COMMITTING HEARING. HAS US IF
HE COULD BECAUSE- AT IT ON AS A
CO AUTHOR ABSOLUTELY AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO BE ADDED ON
TO. THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WOULD MEAN THOSE NOTES
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE SEEING NINE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. WITH THAT- IS DIRECTLY
COLOR. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
YOUR PREPARATIONS BURKE. BURKE
HI WHEN I WHEN I GREAT. GRAYSON
HI GRAYSON HI LEVINE. LEVINE I
MAYES MAYES FIVE MULLIN MULLIN
ABSENT PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS HI CORK HIGH
COURT HI THREE OF US
THREE OF US RSA ARE TOUGH. PHIL
HAS EIGHT BUCKS NOT BULLETS OUT
MOVING TO YOUR NEXT FILE ITEM
AB EIGHT SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU
MA'AM TERM MEMBERS- FOR
INSULTING ME IN ANOTHER BILL AT
TODAY'S AB EIGHT SEVENTY NINE
THE CALIFORNIA TAX AMNESTY AND
REVENUE RECOVERY ACT. THIS
MEASURE IS ONE OF MANY
INTRODUCED THIS YEAR BY THE
LEGISLATURE AIMING TO HELP OUR
STATE RECOVER FROM THE FISCAL
STRAIN OF THE PAST YEAR WITH
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
UNEMPLOYED AND THOUSANDS OF
BUSINESSES HAMPERED BY THE
PANDEMIC THE STATE MUST USE ALL
TOOLS AVAILABLE TO STABILIZE
AND REBUILD OUR REVENUE SOURCES
SECOND. AB EIGHT SEVENTY NINE
IS ONE OF THESE TOOLS I WOULD
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA TAX
AMNESTY AND REVENUE RECOVERY
ACT THIS MEASURE WILL PROVIDE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR TAXPAYERS TO
CLEAR OUTSTANDING TAX LIABILITY
OWED FOR PRIOR TAX YEARS BY
PAYING A DEFINED AMOUNT USING
THE UNDERLYING TAX LIABILITY IN
RETURN FOR A WAIVER OF A PURE.
ARE CRUDE PENALTIES MARC
MODELED AFTER THE STATE'S
PREVIOUS SUCCESSFUL TAX AMNESTY
PROGRAMS MOST RECENTLY IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE TAX AMNESTY
IS A PROVEN AND EFFECTIVE TOOL
THAT DEMONSTRATES A CREATIVE
SOLUTION FOR DRYING IN REVENUE
WITHOUT ISSUING ADDITIONAL TAX
BURDENS INCENTIVIZING NON
COMPLIANT TAXPAYERS TO COME
FORWARD IN GOOD FAITH CREATES A
PATHWAY FOR FAMILIES TO EMERGE
FROM PASSED YOU LIABILITIES
WITHOUT THE FEAR OF SIGNIFICANT
PENALTIES. IN ADDITION TO
HELPING STRUGGLING TAXPAYERS
THIS MEASURE ALSO PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE TO
GENERATE SIGNIFICANT REVENUE IN
TIMES OF FINANCIAL UNCERTAINTY
BUT TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
AMNESTY PROGRAM BROUGHT IN A
TOTAL GROSS REVENUE OF OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THIS WAS OFF THIS WAS HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS HIGHER
THAN EXPECTED WHICH
DEMONSTRATED THE VOLUME UP
TAXPAYERS THAT WERE LOOKING TO
COME HOLE WITH THEIR TAX
LIABILITIES IN GOOD FAITH. AB
EIGHT SEVENTY NINE AS WRITTEN
PROVIDES A SIMILAR OUTLOOK WITH
STDS TWENTY TWENTY ONE ANALYSIS
PROJECTING GROSS REVENUES OF
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED MILLION ASK
THE WITH THE PREVIOUS.
ITERATION THERE IS GREAT
POTENTIAL FOR THAT TO BE ON
UNDER ESTIMATE OF ACTUAL READ.
GEN FOR THIS MEASURE. ALL OF
THIS WITHOUT RAISING ANY
EXISTING TAXES. AB EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE PROVIDES THE
UNIQUE AND CREATIVE FRAMEWORK
THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO
STABILIZE REVENUE SOURCES AND
REDUCE TAX BURDENS ON
STRUGGLING ENTITIES. THIS BILL
ENJOYS A BROAD COALITION OF
SUPPORT FROM THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND CURRENTLY HAS NO
OPPOSITION. HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY IS DESTINED WHETHER BE
WITH THE- WITH THE SPONSOR OF
THIS MEASURE THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION. NOW
PLEASE OPEN THE MAIN LINE FOR
A- MISTER MISTER WEATHERBEE.
ONE MOMENT MISTER WEATHERBEE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND- GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR CAN HEAR
ME YES. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT'S WHY TO BE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT SEVENTY NINE THE
CALIFORNIA TAX AMNESTY AND
REVENUE RECOVERY ACT BEFORE I
GET STARTED I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO AND
HER STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK
ON THIS BILL. YEAH COMMITTEE
STAFFER THERE NOW SYSTEM ARE
LEGISLATION MEMBERS AS WE KNOW
THE LAST YEAR HAS BEEN
UNPRECEDENTED AND MANY OF OUR
LIVES LAST FEBRUARY THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY WAS STRONG
WINDOW SIGNS OF SLOWING DOWN IN
THE SPAN OF TWO MONTHS THE
ACCOUNT THE ECONOMY GROUND TO A
HALT AS GOVERNMENTS AROUND THE
WORLD REACTED THE KOBE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THOUSANDS OF
BUSINESSES CLOSED UP SALAS
REDDIT CODE IT AND SUDDENLY
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
THE UNEMPLOYMENT LINES
CALIFORNIA'S UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
ROSE THREE POINT 9% IN FEBRUARY
TO SIXTEEN POINT 4% IN APRIL.
SO WE MILLION CALIFORNIANS LOST
INCOME AND MILLION IN MANY OF
THOSE CASES THEIR ONLYSOURCE
OF INCOME AND BUSINESSES ACROSS
THE STATE DRASTICALLY LOTS
INCOME RESULTING EMPLOYEE
LAYOFFS AND UNFORTUNATELY
BUSINESS CLOSURES. TAXPAYERS
HAD AN UNDERLYING TAX
OBLIGATION HEADING TO TWENTY
TWENTY WHO MAY HAVE UNDER
REPORTED TAXES SUDDENLY WERE
LEFT IN THE SITUATION OF EITHER
PAYING THEIR TAXES OR USE THE
MONEY TO PAY MORTGAGES OR RENT
KEEP FOOD ON THE TABLE OR TO
CALIFORNIANS EMPLOYED FOR AS
LONG AS THEY COULD- PAY TAXES
RESULT IN LARGE PENALTIES THAT
CAN DRASTICALLY MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR STRUGGLING
TAXPAYERS TO REMAIN AFLOAT.
WELL THE GOVERNOR HAS TAKEN
ACTION TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS THE CURRENT RELIEF
OFFERED IT IN FOR ALL CURRENT
TAX LIABILITIES IS ONLY
TEMPORARY IN FOR TAXES FEES
ADMITTED ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION.
CURRENTLY THE RELIEF TO TAXES
OR FEES DUE ON APRIL DUE ON OR
BY APRIL THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WHAT IS RELIEF
EXPIRES TAXPAYERS WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL TAXES AND
INTEREST ACCRUED SINCE THE
GOVERNOR'S ORIGINAL ACTION
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY AND COULD
BE SUBJECT TO PENALTIES IF NOT
PAID ON TIME. EIGHT AB EIGHT
THING I WILL PROVIDE A
PERMANENT SOLUTION FOR
TAXPAYERS RESOLVE THOSE TAX
LIABILITIES WHAT MORNING COSTLY
PENALTIES MEMBERS EIGHT EIGHTY
EIGHT THIRTY NINE IS. GOOD TAX
POLICY THAT BUILDS UPON THE
EVERY PREVIOUS BELIEF PROVIDE
THESE TAXPAYERS AND- WHO ARE
STRUCK IN THE CO. NINETEEN
PANDEMIC SETTLE THE OBLIGATE
AND HOLDEN. IT REQUIRES THE-
AND- YEAH HM. THE PROGRAM FOR
ALL TAX YEARS TO JAN FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TAXPAYERS
WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM
WILL STILL PAY HE UNDERLYING
TAXES INTERESTS INCLUDE ON THE
TAX. IN EXCHANGE FOR THE WAVING
OF THE PENALTIES ASSESSED ON
THAT TAX. DURING THE
UNPRECEDENTED UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES WE SHOULD DO ALL WE CAN
TO LIMIT LARGE PENALTIES
ASSESSED ON TAXPAYERS. WHO FACE
EXTREME FINANCIAL HARDSHIP THE
REP NO FAULT OF THE REALM. CAL
TAX IN OUR COALITION OF
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
ASSOCIATION. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT SUPPORT AT
EIGHTY EIGHT SEVENTY NINE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR TIME. MODERATOR WE YOU
KNOW THE LINE FOR- AND
ADDITIONAL- CERTAINLY- COMMENTS
PRESS ONE ZERO WE GO NOT A LINE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION LEGISLATOR
BURKE. YES MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KEVIN COULD RODDY
REPRESENTING NFIB- WERE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND-
THANKFUL FOR THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
FOR CARRYING THIS BILL THANK
YOU. AND WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE
FORTY SEVEN GO HEAD. BUDGET
LLOYD GETTING ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AT THE
PORT OF AB EIGHT SEVEN. WE ARE
NOT ALIGNED TWENTY FOUR FOUR
AND YOUR OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS KATE
BELL ON BEHALF OF RYAN LLC IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
UNLESS WE HAVE ONE FORTY FIVE
GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
PRESSING YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO THIS IS DENNIS I'LL BE ON
THE HALF OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION WE AREN'T
SUPPORTERS WELL THANK YOU. I
WOULD CONSTRUCT ONE ZERO PLEASE.
AT NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
ACUTE UP CURRY AND- SOME IN THE
CALL ROOM. NOPE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NONE OF MY IF YOU
COULD OPEN THE LINE FOR ANY
TESTIMONY. PROPOLIS PLEASE
PRESS ONE TWO TIME. NO
OPPOSITION IS QUEUED UP. THANK
YOU- ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
REMOTE VIDEO ROOM. IN THE
HEARING ROOM NINE. ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
DR WORK. SO YOU NEED OUT OF
THEIR HOUSES. NUMBER I KNOW YOU
CASES- AND AMENDMENTS OF THE
RETROACTIVE YEAH- FISHING
FICTIONAL- COMMENTS HERE
RUNNING.YEAH FOR EXAMPLE- THIS
BILL IMPOSES LEGAL PENALTIES
YEAH G. RIGHT IS REASONABLE AND-
FIFTY S. WITHIN FOR THE WAY
THAT YOU DEFINE A- AND- FINALLY-
ARE YOU GONNA IN THIS TWO WEEKS
THE OTHER THING ABSOLUTE I'VE
BEEN WERE WITH THE COMMITTEE I
DON'T HAVE MY MICROPHONE ON
BASE IT JUST FOR PEOPLE WHO DID
I HURT YOU. SHE IS GOING TO
TAKE ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS FOR
ALL OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WERE
RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
THEREFORE I'M GOING TO BE
VOTING ON IT THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION ABSOLUTELY- YOU KNOW
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK- THE CHAIRWOMAN AND ON
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US IT IS A COMPLICATED
MATTER AS WE ALL KNOW- BY TWO-
THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS TO
NOT JUST SUPPORT BUSINESSES BUT
ALSO TO SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS YOU
KNOW IT'S A VERY. TOUGH TIME
THAT WE'RE GOING TO END CORRECT
WE ARE NOT GOING BACK TO- TO
THE SEVENTEEN HUNDREDS WHEN WE
STARTED TALKING PEOPLE I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO YOU KNOW I TAKE
THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND YOU
KNOW THE GOAL AGAIN IS FOR
FOLKS TO FEEL COMFORTABLE AND
BASICALLY START HAVE A BLANK
SLATE WHEN THEY COME WE ALL
COME OUT OF THE PANDEMIC AND
YOU KNOW TAX LIABILITY THE BUT
THE BIG DEAL YOU KNOW SOME
FOLKS LOSE HOMES OVER THIS AND
AGAIN A PROVIDING THIS THIS
RELIEF I THINK WILL HELP NOT
JUST BUSINESSES BUT AGAIN
PERSONAL OF FOLKS THAT HAVE
PERSONAL INCOME TAX ISSUES. AND
SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AYE AGAIN THANK ON
THE CHAIRWOMAN AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY IT'S ALWAYS
A WORK IN PROGRESS THIS IS OUR
FIRST COMMITTEE AND I'M I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IS WHEN IT COMES
OUT- THAT THIS IS A GOOD FOR
ALL AND WE ADDRESS THE ISSUES-
PRIMARY OF THE PANDEMIC. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS ARE
FROM THE- FINO LIKE CLOSE YES
THANK YOU THIS IS A LARGE AND
SCOPING PROGRAM AS WE JUST-
STATED AT THE POTENTIAL TO BE
AN INCREDIBLY VALUABLE TOOL FOR
BOTH THE STATE AND CONSTITUENTS
AGAINST NOT JUST BUSINESSES BUT
ALSO FOR PERSONAL INCOME TAX- I
WANT TO THANK BOTH THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
TIRELESS WORK ON THIS MEASURE.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
IMPLEMENTING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS I AS WE HAD
JUST- THE MEASURE TO A
CALIFORNIA'S RECOVERY I'M ALSO
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDED TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SO I JUST WORKED.
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I'M CLEAR
SO YOU'RE YOU'RE GONNA TAKE
COULD BE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
AND THEN THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT ARE IN THE ANALYSIS OKAY
SO THEN MY RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
LANCASTER OF WHO TO. CALL THE
ROLL. MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE
THANKS BURKE I WENT. WHEN I
GREAT. GREAT I GRAYSON FIVE
GRAYSON AYE LEVINE LEVINE AYE
MAYES AYE MAYES AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN ABSENTEE TRAYNOR'S
PETRIE-NORRIS HIGH COURT HI
BURKE AYE THREE OF US THIS
RESIDES THERE ARE TOO HI THERE
TO ALL RIGHT. HAS TEN VOTES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ASSUME I
REALLY MEAN TO YOU READY. LET'S
DO IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
FORTINO TOO WILL REQUIRE A
MARKETPLACE FACILITATOR TO
REGISTER COLLECT AND REMIT ALL
APPLICABLES FEES REQUIRED TO BE
ADMINISTERED UNDER THE FEE
COLLECTION PROCEDURES LAWS BY
REQUIRING MARKET PLACE FOR
SOLICITORS TO COLLECT AND REMIT
THE RELEVANT FEES THIS BILL
WHAT HAS COMPLIANCE FUND
CRITICAL ENVIRONMENTAL
MITIGATION AND REDUCE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON
SMALLER MARKET PLACE SELLERS.
WITH AN INCREASED USE OF
E-COMMERCE FOR RETAIL PURCHASES
ONLINE RETAILERS HAVE SHIFTED
TO SELLING THEIR PRODUCTS TO
PLATFORMS CALLED MARKETPLACE
FACILITATORS UNDER EXISTING LAW
MARKET PLACE'S SOLICITORS
COLLECT INTERNET SALES AND USE
TAXES WHICH IS HELPFUL TO
SMALLER RETAILERS AND THE STATE
TO REDUCE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN
ON RETAILERS AND INCREASE THE
COMPLIANCE HOWEVER FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH SPECIFIC
PRODUCTS ARE STILL BEING
COLLECTED BY THE RETAILERS
THEMSELVES CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
COLLECTS FEES ON PRODUCTS TO
MITIGATE THEIR IMPACT ON OUR
ENVIRONMENT FOR INSTANCE THE
STATE COLLECTS FEES. WHEN NEW
TIRES ARE SOLD WITH THOSE HE'S
GOING TOWARDS GRANTS FOR TYRE
RECYCLERS IN PROGRAMS TO FIGHT
AIR POLLUTION. THE STATE ALSO
COLLECTS FEES ON THE SALE OF
REPLACEMENT LEAD ACID BATTERIES
WITH THOSE FUNDS GOING TOWARD
CLEANUP AND MONITORING SITES
THAT HAVE BEEN CONTAMINATED BY
THE OPERATION OF LEAD ACID
BATTERY RECYCLING FACILITIES.
THESE FEES HELP REDUCE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT OF THESE
PRODUCTS AND DIVERTS THE VOLUME
OF THESE OFTEN TOXIC PRODUCTS
FROM ENTERING OUR LANDFILLS. AT
LEAST NINE STATES ALREADY
REQUIRE MARKETPLACES SOLICITORS
TO COLLECT DURING THAT SPECIFIC
PRODUCT OR SERVICE FEES OR
TAXES IN ADDITION TO SALES AND
USE TAX. AB FORTINO TO ALLIANCE
ONLINE MARKETPLACE FEE
COLLECTIN AND REMITTANCE WITH
THE RELEVANT EXISTING PROCESS
FOR SALES AND USE TAX
UTILIZING EXISTING
TECHNOLOGICAL RESOURCES IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE RESPONSIBLE
ONLINE COMMERCE THAT SUPPORTS
RETAILERS CONSUMERS AND THE
ENVIRONMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYONE ON THE MAIN
LINE FOR SUPPORT TESTIMONY. YOU
HEAR ME. TO SAY ANYTHING OKAY
ANYONE THE VIDEO CONFERENCING
MARKET. WHEN IN THE HEARING
ROOM SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYONE THE PROPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ACT ON
HOFFMAN DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT CENSOR INTERNET
ASSOCIATION- AND APPETITE
RESTRICTIONS POSE. AB FOURTEEN
R. TWO- BY WAY OF BACKGROUND I
REPRESENTS ONE FORTY OF THE
WORLD'S LEADING INTERNET
COMPANIES INCLUDING SEVERAL
ONLINE MARKETPLACES- ONE OF OUR
MAIN CONCERNS OF MAYBE
FORTUNATE TO IS THE WAY THAT IT
UNDERMINES POTENTIALLY THE
LANGUAGE OF AB ONE FORTY SEVEN
FROM ACT TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN-
AB ONE FORTY SEVEN
REPRESENTATIVES AGREEMENT THAT
PARK PLACES WOULD BE CONSIDERED
THE RETAILERS FOR SALES TAX
PURPOSES ONLY. I AB FOURTEEN R.
TWO HOWEVER EFFECTIVELY
CONSIDERS A MARKETPLACE
RETAILER FOR PURPOSES. OF OTHER
TAXES AND FEES READ BELIEVE
THIS MAY BE FORTUNATE TO DOES
HARDLY CAN BE APPROPRIATE TO
INCLUDE ANY DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION DATE- SIMILAR TO
EIGHTY ONE FORTY SEVENTIES
COMPLIANCE- FOR COMPANIES.
ADDITIONALLY AB FOURTEEN R. TWO
APPLIES AB ONE QUESTION FALL
APPROACH THAT DOESN'T ACCOUNT
FOR THE DIVERSITY OF BUSINESS
MODELS THAT EXIST IN ONLINE
COMMERCE FOR MANY OF OUR
MARKETPLACES IT WOULD BE
DIFFICULT TO ASCERTAIN WHICH
FEES SHOULD BE COLLECTED ABOUT
IT BECAUSE- THEY SIMPLY DON'T
HAVE OR MAINTAIN AN INVENTORY-
LET ALONE THE STOCK KEEPING
UNIT SYSTEM AS AS MANY
RETAILERS DO- SO THIS WOULD BE
A BURKE OWNERSHIP. ONEROUS AND
BURDENSOME REQUIREMENTS AFTER
THESE MARKETPLACES TO CREATE A
NEW SYSTEM TO TRACK AND MANAGE-
WHICH YOU SHOULD BE COLLECTED
AND REMITTED AND FOR WHICH
PRODUCTS. SEARCH FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
AB FORTUNATE TO I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
WITH YOUR DOCTOR'S OFFICE ON.
THIS MATTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER WITNESS ENOUGH. SEEN
ON ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IN THE VIDEO ROOM. ANY IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NINE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. YES SIR. SO AS I
UNDERSTAND THE BELL JUST IN ITS
SIMPLEST FORM IF I'M SELLING
SOMETHING ON EBAY THIS WOULD
REQUIRE EBAY TO COLLECT THE TAX
AND REMIT. WE ALREADY HAVE THEM
COLLECTING DATA STATE TAXES
WOULD REQUIRE THEM TO COLLECT
THERE ARE FOUR FEES THAT THIS
WILL ALSO REQUIRE THEM TO
COLLECT AND ENERGIZING YEAH SO
WE ONE FORTY SEVEN IS LONG PAST
WE ARE BENEFITING FROM THAT.
REGULARLY BUT THIS WOULD JUST
ADD FOR OTHER FEES THAT THEY
HAVE TO WORK AT TO. COLLECT AS
WELL OKAY SO AS THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL MENTIONED I THINK THIS
IS A GREAT BILL I THINK IT JUST
COMPLETES THE CIRCLE ON WHAT WE
WHAT WE ARE AND ONE FORTY SEVEN
I CAN ASSURE YOU IS SOMEONE WHO
SELLS THINGS ON EBAY FROM TIME
TO TIME I WOULD DATE NO IDEA
THAT THESE FEES EVEN EXIST. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
YES. I'M NOT SURE THERE'S A- IN
ONE OF THE OPPOSITION LETTERS-
IT. MAKES THE CLAIM THAT THIS
BILL UNDERMINES- THAT CAREFULLY
NEGOTIATE LANGUAGE OF AB ONE
FORTY SEVEN- AND SO. I THOUGHT
MAYBE SINCE YOU ARE THE AUTHOR
OF THAT IF YOU COULD TALK
BECAUSE IT'S NEVER GOOD. TO
MAKE A DEAL IF YOU WILL TO
NEGOTIATE SOMETHING AND THEN
AFTERWARDS- BREAK THAT DEAL
THERE RIGHT AFTER SO CAN YOU
CLARIFY THAT A BIT I HAPPILY
WILL CLARIFY THAT I WAS IN THE
ROOM IN THAT CONVERSATION HAD I
HAD IT WITH THE- WITH THE
FOLKS. I WHAT MY BILL DID WAS
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THIS BILL
DID AND WAS NEVER EVER WAS IT
COMMENTED ON THAT THIS BILL
WOULD NEVER MOVE FORWARD. THAT
THESE FEES WOULD NEVER BE
COLLECTED. AND IT WAS NEVER
STATED IT WAS NEVER PART OF THE
CONVERSATION WE WERE VERY VERY
FOCUSED AND WE HAVE HAD THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND MADE SURE THAT
THEY REMEMBER THINGS CORRECTLY.
TO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR IT'S GREAT TO HAVE
SOMEONE WITH THAT AS MUCH
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS ISSUE AS
YOU CHAIRING THE COMMITTEE TO
BE ABLE TO COMMENT AND ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS I APPRECIATE IT
GREATLY THANK YOU AND I SPOKE
LAST FOR AN AYE VOTE. WITHOUT
MR UP TO CALL THE ROLL. I
BELIEVE WE NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND. I CANGET IT. FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO PROVIDE
BURKE HI BURKE I WENT. WHEN NO
GREAT. GRAYSON HI GRAYSON AYE
LEVINE I MEAN I MAYES. AS NOT
VOTING. ABSENT FIRST.
PETRIE-NORRIS HI CORK WINE
BURKE HI THIS RIVAS SERVICE
FIVE ZERO TWO NO- TO KNOW. THE
BILL HAS SIX SETS GREAT THANK
YOU ON TOP OF OUR HEAD SIX BOTH.
SENT OUT SIX MONTHS OKAY.
THANKS VERY MUCH ITEM CHECK-
MEMBERS VERY QUICKLY BEFORE WE
DO OUR VOTE ONLY I WOULD LIKE
TO SEND OUR OUR CONSOLES
CONDOLENCES TO OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBER AND FRIEND KEVIN MULLIN
HAS LOST HIS FATHER SO FROM OUR
STAFF HERE AND ALL OF THE
MEMBERS HERE- WE ARE VERY IS
GREATLY SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS AND
WE'VE MISSED YOU THE LAST FEW
WEEKS THAT YOU'VE BEEN TAKING
CARE OF YOUR FAMILY. THANK YOU
SO WITH THAT THE LAST. GIVE IT
GIVE PERCENT WHICH IS BEING
TAKEN UP FOR VOTE ONLY THE BILL
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE CHAIR WITH THAT DO WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND MOVE
THE BILL. THE SECOND. OH WAIT.
MY BILL'S GONE CALL. DURING
OPEN THE RAW. CAN I OPEN THE
ROLE ON AN- ISLAND WHAT NUMBER
IS IT O I FILE ITEM EIGHT- AB.
TWELVE OH THREE. YEAH CAN I
TELL. HI I'M CALLING ABSENT ON
FILE ITEM AB TWO OH THREE FIVE.
GREAT ALL RIGHT RIGHT I. THE I
LEVINE I. THREE OF US THIS
RIVAS ICE THERE ARE TWO NOW
THEY ARE TWO NOW. BILL HAS
EIGHT VOTES THANK YOU HAVE
BILLS THAT OKAY RETURNING
THAILAND SIX AB TWO NINETY SIX
MISTER RUFF WOULD YOU PLEASE-
DO WE GET A MOTION AND SECOND
LEADING THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
MISTER A FEW CALL THE ROLL.
PROFESSIONISTI PASTOR
PREPARATION BURKE HI. BURKE HI
WENT. WHEN HIGH GREAT. IT'S. HI
GREAT HI GRAYSON HI GRAYSON HI
LEVINE AYE LEVINE AYE MAYES.
MAYES FIVE MILLION MULLIN APPS
PETRIE-NORRIS. PETRIE-NORRIS HI
COURT HI WORK BY THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIR HI THERE ARE.
FIVE THE- BILL HAS TURNED UP.
WELL YOU WANTED WE ARE ALL THE
OTHER ITEMS. AFTER SORRY WE ARE
THE ROLE FOR THE ABSENT ON THE
OTHER ITEMS FILE I WOULD
CLARIFYING- THE VOTE ON AB TWO
NINE SIX WAS TEN. TO ZERO YES
NONSTOP TEND TO ZERO AND I BILL
IS OUT OKAY RIGHT RETAIN TO.
FILE ITEM. WELL HELLO WE TO DO
ONLY BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
BECAUSE LOSE LEFT PARTLY O
STILL LET'S READ. FILE ITEM TO
AB FORTINO. TO CALL THEM
MEMBERS. FILE ITEM TO GREAT.
MAYES. THAT'S ALL I HAVE ALL
RIGHT MOVING THE FILE ITEM
THREE ABC TEN SIXTY FIVE. FILE
ITEM THREE WHEN I. THREE OF US
THREE OF US I SWEAR. TO ZERO
FIVE. FILE ITEM FOR AB. EIGHT
THIRTY SEVEN. GREAT. CERAKOTE
HI WE ARE TOO HIGH. FILE ITEM.
FIVE EIGHT SEVENTY NINE. YOU
HAVE ALL THE VOTES FOR THAT
MEASURE OKAY AND THEN FILE ITEM
SIX AB TWO NINETY SIX. OF ALL
THE VOTES FOR THE MEASURE AS
WELL. WITH THAT WE ARE JOINED.